hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca on foreigner again today
is Thursday is Dave's to recap date now
there really wasn't much to talk about
so we're just without further hesitation
I'm just gonna go right into it so we
can get on with her day like I said
there really wasn't much room it was
probably about a half an hour and
majority of that was dedicated to the
community corner where they show off
some of the clips from the stream in the
community as well so first up we have
the new content of the week which is
battle outfits
yes battle outfits are not entirely
exciting but they are still new content
if you do want to grab those you
definitely can they don't seem too bad
but I personally do not like battle off
it so I'm gonna keep my steel on top of
that does a ranked warrior challenge be
the faction with the most amount of
ranked matches definitely go play that
if you do want to do that as well
the winning faction will get for XP
tickets which is going to be pretty
helpful if you're going to be trying to
grind the new characters get some extra
XP and stuff like that without wasting
any self which I definitely do that if
you want to participate there's also
gonna be execution discounts I don't
exactly remember what the executions
work because they mentioned a couple and
then said and more so it'll either be
all of them or just the single bunch of
them either way there's going to be a
few executions that are gonna be
discounted from 7,000 still there are
now 4,000 so check your characters that
you play if the execution you want is
this count and go grab a while you got
the chance you have an entire week I
believe and then to end we have the new
arcade quest now I do not know if this
is going to be the same exact effect as
last week or if it's an entirely
different effect I have no idea I
haven't actually had the chance to play
it just yet I just recently got home so
after this video I'm gonna go hop on and
test my theory and see if we get a new
one or we keep the old one either way
I'm actually really cool with either of
the options but yeah that's gonna be the
end of the video today but there's one
really quick thing I want to bring up
and it's I noticed this a lot and in the
comments of the livestream and stuff
like that and it's that the devs didn't
mention that there was supposed to be
balance well they're not supposed to be
balanced they were talking about the
balance updates they brung it to the
team and they're still discussing it but
someone mentioned that they should have
a weekly balance patch instead of a
weekly content because no one really
likes battle outfits so let me know your
thoughts on that and I just really want
the balance stuff to come out a lot more
frequently because this game hasn't
really been changing all that often and
characters that need buffs are not
getting them and care
that may need a slight change your nerve
aren't getting them either and it's just
delaying this whole game of this all
does bad stuff so hopefully they come
out with a balanced pass hopefully next
week or in the next two weeks because
I'd be really excited to see what
they're doing hopefully they don't [ __ ]
it up or anything like that but yeah let
me know your guys thoughts on all that
let me know if you guys think that they
should come out with more balanced
updates and even if it's something
really small like a couple updates or a
couple nerfs or Buffs a week let me know
your thoughts in the comments below and
yeah guys like the video and rest
discography newer cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being balance changes hero updates
passionately to leaks all that good
stuff and that guys my two most recent
videos would be on the screen if you
guys do want to check that out guys
thank you guys for watching the video
and a peace out
you